hello everyone welcome to the Wyatt lump
that was a great intro welcome to the
lobby i'm peter brown not Danny O'Dwyer
he's in Ireland this week but the lobby
continues its gamespot's a weekly video
game chat show at two p.m. pacific you
can check it out at gamespot or twitch
TV / gamespot and on iTunes as a podcast
I encourage you to do so because it
works very well in that format today we
were talking about the division the
cancellation of fable legends and tim
sweeney from epic talked a little smack
about microsoft but we're can get things
started i'm joined by rob handlery hi
butterworth below hello boys you played
a lot of the division lately right yeah
a lot yeah I think we're obviously a
little more than me but yeah it's been
since yesterday morning's it's been like
division time go so yes unlike most
games we did not get this early yeah so
you guys are playing like the real deal
retail servers at launch yeah correct
how has that been so far I know some
games like Street Fighter had some
problems with their servers but the
division seems to be going pretty well
yeah I mean nothing compared to the
problem Street Fighter head for sure
yeah I mean you hear like issues like a
little bit like for me like I've been
fine I've been completely fine as far as
joining up and playing with other people
saying a breeze but you know once a
while like I play with Eric hey
Australia for a very long marathon which
you can check out on video games does
right he unfortunately had a couple
crashes no big deal and that's all on
reddit this morning there was an issue I
don't know if it was just for PC but it
was a photo of this huge line for like
one of the first missions and no one was
able to like basically hold f oh yeah so
it in the game starts everyone has to go
to the same shared safe room and in that
room there is one laptop that you have
to like walk up to and hit a button
prompt to initiate a certain mission so
you have a room full of like actual live
human players who all need to use the
same laptop and apparently rooms have
been so populated that people can't
physically move their character to the
laptop to engage the prom that sounds
ridiculous it's literally a line it's
the funniest image it's like two dozen
people just in a line one laptop it's so
funny that everyone would like even line
up to do that okay cool I think Rob and
I both avoided that problem and we
haven't seen anything that
stupid since then there have been other
smaller issues but that's like just kind
of a funny situation but you guys have
gotten into the game and plated a bunch
so I'm really curious I'm assuming you
both had some experience with the beta
how many things change since then it was
only a couple weeks ago but now we have
the whole game like what's what's new
how do things feel any different the
only concerns I had were like just
quantity all around like uh you know
more NPCs more AI to battle in the dark
zone all of that for the most part has
been fixed if if not surprising how
alive this huge new york city is like
for me and like as a recap of how i feel
i'm like having a really great time with
this game i mean i haven't necessarily
been just utterly blown away by the
world but certainly there's a lot more
going on and it feels more alive than it
did in the beta as i can definitely
agree with that it's really cool to be
wandering around you hear somebody say
something nearby but yeah what's like
where did that come from and you look up
and you see people are actually like in
the buildings that are you're walking
underneath just kind of a cool touch you
notice things like that as you wander
around and you know i haven't seen too
many like reused assets or anything they
did a pretty good job of making streets
feel kind of unique so far everything
I've seen has just been you know exactly
what you expect it's an urban
environment and ruin and their cars
strewn about but you know within that
context they've they've done a pretty
good job of making the environments feel
diverse and like you're saying a little
more alive so I'm curious because this
is a sort of a dark story you know the
city is under horrible disease like the
society itself has sort of changed as a
result Rob you were telling me about
some the mutant dark stuff that is
and learn to share some of that yeah uh
so many elements of just like you take a
step back and go wow this is like
they're not holding anything back and
telling this really dark story which I
am no one really knows it's basically
you know Black Friday terrorists have
devised a successful form of smallpox
embedded in all the paper currency in
New York City and everyone's got
smallpox and everyone's dying so you're
constantly just walking around the city
just body bags or like one missions a
huge incinerator well they're just
throwing bodies into a it's like dark
there's like literally a waterfall of
bodies and bags it's like pouring into a
pit of fire okay cool yeah and with that
in mind it is a very grounded story in
that you know it's not too far in the
future it's like you know this could
happen right it's a Tom Clancy thriller
this could happen and you're constantly
reminded of like you know these factions
you know some people want to just
basically burn everything or some people
want to take advantage of this uprising
and and you know go rogue and you know
take on the government yeah there are
these you know they have collectibles
with little cinematics one of them being
like this scene where it's a it's a girl
on a cell phone so you get like a cell
phone video and she's you know in a room
and they're these guys called cleaners
and they come in and they got flame
throwers and they just torch everything
and she's hiding from them and she's you
know in like a market so she's looking
through cracks and she's you think she's
okay and then gustl snow and wind goes
right past the camera meaning there's
someone behind her and she opens up into
the flamethrower guy is there looking at
her almost reminds me pyro from like
team fortress or he's like looking at
her and [ __ ] his head just because he
has a flamethrower he's really dark and
then he kills her and she's screaming so
that's and then you hear audio if her
screaming and being burned alive and
that type of stuff happens all the time
yeah most of that kind of content is
comes from like the collectibles story
is clearly not the focus of the division
it's you know you're not getting a cut
scene every couple steps or anything
like that this is not Hideo Kojima game
but if you're looking for collectibles
you can absolutely find like cell phone
videos
audio recordings things like that and
those tend to be both the darkest and
you know do the most kind of flesh out
the world i mean there's another one you
found that I that I also found pretty
early on of like it's a bunch of
security camera footage you have two
guys running for a bunch of looters and
it's like pretty harrowing watching them
let trip over themselves and of course
they like run into a gate and can't get
past and get caught and just like
basically beaten to death and you know
tastefully cuts away before it shows any
real gore or anything but it's you know
obviously implied that they're being
brutally murdered yeah and like it's
yeah it's pretty unflinching but at the
same time there are moments where you
kind of have to ignore the world that
this game is set in in a weird way like
I mean the most basic most obviously you
can point to you is the fact that it
just takes a long time to kill anybody
dudes and hoodies and jackets can
withstand like three or four head shots
before they die so goodies then again
apparently and I mean like that's a
widely known thing and you know people
who like to defend the game will always
point out that all it's an RPG and I
shooter but it's still just ematic alia
is odd to be shooting app Uman and then
watch them just like completely shrug
off bullets and like barely even react
and stuff like that and i also have a
bit of a hard time getting past the fact
that you know you're this sort of
peacekeeping unit and your job is to
kind of clean up and you know restore
order in the city but literally the only
way you do that is just like wandering
around killing people but you will just
see looters in the street who like are
not engaging you who are not threatening
but because they're that particular
character model you know that they are
like the looter enemy class and you know
that as soon as they notice you they're
going to shoot you so even if they
haven't done anything your job as the
gamers like well I gotta kill him
because if I don't they're gonna shoot
me and so this is weird thematic
disconnect of like you kind of have to
ignore the world that you're in to make
it all make sense you know that's a
beautiful segue into a question from sir
plaintiffs in the chat why don't people
slip over in the snow this you're good
at it I mean so the agents were all
there embedded in like their active in
New York because they were living in New
York art so they're seasoned pros they
know what they're doing they gotta have
that like gingerly walk yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah my step don't shuffle my
trendy mountain boots are doing just
yeah click boots so many great great
game for food
that mention one thing those yeah I
agree if you like you know you do see
the looters and yes if you don't engage
they will I'm sorry if you just approach
them they're gonna gauge you however you
know on the flip side you'll you'll turn
a corner and you'll see a looter
hovering over a distressed you know
civilian who's standing there and satin
this happens couple times but it's a
really interesting thing work she's got
back and he's saying like you're
worthless like what are you gonna do
about it if you don't kill him before he
basically just takes this woman down
beats her and then if you didn't engage
he's just gonna continually beat her
dead body it's like here's witnessing
this and I think I've had that happen
like three or four times and I've only
been able to shoot him like twice before
he kills her it's like there's still
like hero element of you you know you
have a good heart and you're going
around trying to prevent the wrongdoings
but it's just like really again like
dark scenarios that make you take a step
back and kind of think like this is kind
of surreal but like surprisingly real
like I don't know like riders in it in
the state of apocalypse like this is
what would happen and I like that idea
of being reminded like how awful
humanity can can kind of unfold and
these scenarios are no it's just yes I
think the game to actually it really
goes out of its way to sort of justify
your actions whenever it can but it
still feels weird that you're just a
total judge dredd type like judge jury
executioner like anyone you see like
death sentence pressure you're behaving
badly death it's just like okay it would
have been nice if there'd been a little
more nuanced but but I agree it's not
you know I don't feel like you know a
horrible human by playing this game or
anything like right it's just like there
are certain moments where the themes
kind of fall apart or come into conflict
with the way that the game actually
plays yeah I means nothing in the world
is just something I've notices they've
been playing yeah and we've got your
early impressions up on the site right
now yeah yeah I mean we always like to
just throw up a page let people know
like no we're reviewing the game but
this is what we don't have a review the
day the game comes got goes up because
we often do so yeah people can go find
my early impressions they can watch the
livestream that Robin Eric recorded
yesterday that's all up there so plenty
of stuff for people to check out even we
don't have a skort review and get a good
sense of like what to
expect from the game maybe we'll find
out more later oh there's so much more
to talk about is there all the the perks
and cover system like you could easily
talk about the game for an entire hour
so and yeah we did the live stream
yesterday but uh having the game before
its release you know the dark zone like
that's still up in the air there we we
did 20 of the stream get in there and
Eric hey did backstab me a few times
just to kind of show what may be the
potential rogue life is but there
weren't really many people playing so
it's hard to tell what that is even
going to be about the people have been
playing the dark zones are like the PvP
area right in the world that you like
consciously enter and then it becomes
this kind of free for all you can sort
of join out with people or not or you
can betray them or take looter it's this
whole crazy thing it seems like maybe
one of the most interesting mechanical
aspects of the game but as Rob pointed
out it's requires a bit of a higher
level so we'll get there we haven't had
a chance to really explore it yet okay
one last question before we go out
Jeffrey sparks wants to know are
collectibles from the dark zone actually
worth it or just Reese kins or different
perks I don't know what he's talking
about is I saw them play the division
but it's hard to tell ah the beta like
pushing aside the beta I would imagine
the idea of or the incentive to go into
dark zone is to get higher valued loot
at the moment during from the beta was
likee that you do missions you do side
missions you the the payoff as far as
Lukos is is alright it's like
substantial but in my opinion the idea
of the dark zone is is to go for those
higher and those purple weapons you know
the better stuff at the moment it's hard
to tell but yeah it seems like it would
kind of have to be I feel like that's
almost the part of the design of the
dark zone but again we haven't actually
spent that much time in the now finished
retail version of the dark soon we most
of our experience was in betas and I
feel like it you know it was worthwhile
in the betas I found you know the best
stuff that I come across all in the dark
zone so I would assume that will be true
in the retail version as well but hard
to confirm I mean like it's there is an
obvious added challenge and just getting
stuff out of the dark zone so it would
only make sense for the developers to
incentivize that gameplay in some way
yeah so
it would be kind of insane if those
items weren't better but we'll we'll see
all right now thank you Scott Raab
talking about the division hmm we will
be playing more the division before a
review goes live later this week have
you been playing are you waiting in line
to press F on that laptop let us know in
the comments below all right Scott we're
gonna swap you out for thai route who's
coming in and on his way in Rob I want
to talk to you about uncharted 4 yeah
gladly everyone by Scott sooner so one
charted for was recently delayed again
it's now coming out in May but there was
a multiplayer beta mm-hmm you played a
bunch of for people who don't know can
give us a sort of a broad overview of
how multiplayer works and uncharted for
sure um well as far as what they showed
in the open beta and there was a
previous beta that was only available
for people who believe if you had the
Uncharted collection you were able to
play for a few days and this is
basically that carried over plus a
mission and arms are a map and I believe
may be a few more abilities but
regardless what they showed off was like
55 just team deathmatch on three maps
and essentially it's yet death match
with new features compared to hate I how
you done great new features that I
looked up on compared to uncharted 3
were like an in-game store so you could
do things you know I kill a guy at down
a guy I get money and then in game I can
basically pull up a store menu and buy a
powerup weapon RPG or something called a
mystic which is like a any anything like
on totem or something exactly i told
them that basically like well you know
throw down its got like splash damage
and it will just kill anyone in the
vicinity but yeah it mean it's it's
super fun I don't have like too much say
about it um you just said a lot though
hey I mean they added a lot of cool
things it's it's a fun game right like
it's things they also added were like if
I if I don't necessarily have to kill a
guy like I'll down him and you're down
and it's pretty silly to see basically
like bunch of people like crawling
around and you're now
trying to basically kick them to get the
confirmed kill so many times you'll see
like butch people like crawling around
and everyone's just like swinging and
missing they're like trying to like kick
and like it looks ridiculous and then I
saw today I didn't see the option but
you could like down someone and then you
could like pull your camera and do a
selfie of course they're having fun with
this game uh and that's pretty apparent
or like other another one was like you
can now do the lasso like grapple and in
the beta they had like up is called like
uncharted TV and there's this clip of
like a dozen people who have grappled
onto one attachment and are doing like a
merry-go-round like swing just for fun
just for fun just swinging around so
like my takeaway is like it's it's a
super fun multiplayer experience uh
that's got some silly aspects to it
awesome yeah thanks for that Rob yeah
yeah ty route our very own Nathan Drake
hello how's it going good how are you
have nothing to add to that conversation
uh boys we're gonna chat a little bit
about fable legends yesterday was
announced that the game has been
cancelled after four years of
development and Microsoft is looking
into possibly closing lionhead studios
in the UK they can't just shutters like
a company they actually have to take 30
days to see if it's a reasonable
decision but for all intensive purposes
it seems like fable legends is
definitely gone maybe the series done
and probably lionhead studios as well
I'm very curious about how you guys feel
about this game tying played a lot of
fable at least one through three how do
you feel about them sort of taking a
game like that that people know and is
sort of defined what it is and turning
it into this this odd like multiplayer
free to play game do you think they're
risking the series by by doing that I
mean it seems to have ended up that way
I think fable three rub so many people
the wrong way yeah I thought this game
was doomed from the start I mean I i
just i don't know if you guys played
three but it was probably the the lowest
point in that series and i think maybe
they were trying to do something
different with doing this whole like
free to play four player co-op thing I
mean that it's weird cuz wasn't the beta
supposed to be like next month or
something
it's been going they're gonna keep it
open until April okay got ya yeah I
never I I I either outgrew fable games
or I just kind of lost interest after 3i
love I think too was the pinnacle of
that series i love to i think they did
so many unique changes from the first
one I loved my dog I still have dreams
right here like you're brewing beer and
just hear this guy go the perfect pint
but 1,500 times like names were that is
just eating non-stop I mean just brewing
beer and that guy just telling me how
great of a job I did but um but yeah I I
don't know I mean I I don't know much
about fable legends I've obviously seen
gameplay I know was announced you know
three years ago and I kind of haven't
heard anything since I just don't think
the buzz was there yeah it's not a
fitting like I said that they had that
what mala news twitter account was
hacked like what two weeks ago saying
he's retired so i think this is kind of
oddly it funny if it's still technically
in open beta is that doesn't mean the
project scanned oh the project is Kansas
gone they're doing is higher at a
goodwill oh ok so the people who are
looking forward to it who had put time
into it Wow now like you get to play
till April and that's it geez yeah
creative director David Eckelberry
speaking to Kotaku back 2015 he was
talking about you know how can they make
this game viable given that it's free to
play and they were trying to avoid sort
of the the shifty practices that make a
lot of free-to-play games money yeah um
he said we need scale pc gives us that
scale element but even with the core
xbox audience we've got a lot to work
with we need millions probably but then
the fable series has always hit those
numbers yeah is it safe to assume that a
company can just play with a series do
whatever they want with it and expect to
get the same sales game after game no i
mean i think i just if anything you
learned it they were just too late on
this I mean now when you have like all
these MOBAs come now I mean think about
like you have battleborn battlecry
Paragon smite you have I mean that was a
big craze right that happened over the
last three years or four years yeah and
then meanwhile there's like this four
player co-op like yeah 32 place like
rotating heroes it sounded yeah and you
could I think they're just late and I
and I think that the audience I don't
know me again like I'm then
older than you guys so maybe I'm just
the old fart who just as tired of
failure and I are no idea at this point
but I think that um I think that's I I
think they took a gamble I don't
actually criticize him for taking a
gamble but I don't think it paid off and
it's clear and it's showing and that's
probably why is a lion heads being
disbanded it's gone well so that's the
thing is that they have a month to
justify the fact that they want a
clothesline what's the other studio that
was working on that was a press play or
press play was yeah I don't know if
they're working on fable legends it work
on another get there a part of the sort
of shuttering that's happening right now
got it over there yeah yeah that was the
yeah I just know that they may have
taken one too many risks they may have
not had the playerbase like you know
when i was in game dev we when you make
a game you you have two especially in a
beta you have to get all those players
to come in and if they don't stick
around you don't offer anything unique I
imagine they were going to go with like
cosmetic items to be more of like the
the pay structure and that's how you get
like returning people that come and
spend money but maybe just wasn't
happening do you guys think the fable
series is done and furthermore can
Microsoft risk having one less exclusive
series under their belt nothing's ever
done Peter no yeah ten years to come
back and reboot this entire thing you
wish I I have a feeling i mean that's
that's kind of like the creator's mantra
right look at hollywood look at gaming
they had to reboot it like 10 years
later how often do things like this get
canceled like so late in development
when they had a fan base like like you
know people who really like fable have
been watching this game for years
nothing for and now Microsoft is
basically saying sorry yeah I don't know
if they can really come back from this
it seems like that's that's sort of put
themselves they dug a little bit of a
dish it'd be it'd be I don't I can't
really think of any other examples where
this has happened before really and
someone's come back so maybe you're
right did the game look promising like
legends we're like what was the response
of like that game as a whole people so I
was reading some previews this morning
people seem to enjoy sort of the eastern
metrical aspect so for people would play
just like the heroes right yeah and then
a different player a fifth player would
play the villain sort of like a dungeon
master like in Dungeons and Dragons gets
to define like where traps are where
enemies are and stuff like that and
people made it sound like look we've got
the fable dressing and environment but
we have this new gameplay where you get
to play you know where your friends gets
to play
a little bit like evolved in that regard
I was going to say that it looks like
they just followed the same path that
evolved in oh crap yeah I mean it's
possible they got a lot of negative
feedback from the beta but I guess we'll
never know yeah I mean as someone who's
only played like a little bit of the
first 1i that would not be an incentive
to go back like my incentive for a fable
game would be like let me play catch-up
and and and see why people love the
lower that the story of it like so I
mean you hear such praise for like yeah
two and one like I'd like to see that
how did you know in another form sorry
interrupted how did the they've release
the original was released like wait last
year like the HD remaster if you write
again did that do well like the
anniversary edition did it do okay I
know we I looked at it it looked great
yeah I just wasn't sure if it was doing
well I'm not quite sure I mean it seems
to me that's sort of like one of those
timeless games it gets a bit of a
facelift right yeah but people still I
think are kind of burned from three
especially like talking to you it sounds
like the series at that point lost
relevance yeah I just think that I mean
you it was weird because it had I mean
that I can see what they were trying to
do with like adding more political
themes and then you like kind of
becoming king and defending your kingdom
against invaders and stuff and it just
too was maybe two is just so good this
is so good they're like crap what do we
do like do we just expand upon that I
don't know I mean you kind of see that
right with like existing games I mean
how innovative is Zelda really you know
it's kind of the same story you know
like they're obviously are some
different games like winwaker and
Skyward Sword are a little different
they look different but yeah for the
most part that formula still there right
i mean do you maybe fable went too far I
just don't know I just member like to
was amazing because you just they really
expanded upon one they perfected
everything you are visited perfected
perfected I would say they perfected
everything everyone yeah you could I
mean like everything you did affected
your character you could drink and eat
pies and just get fat or you could eat
celery and get like really thin just
like real life yeah it's exactly real
you know you could marry you could marry
people you had same-sex marriage you
could [ __ ] a hooker you know that's some
language yeah hold the phone I'm sure
they're laughing back there yeah
anyways the whole thing end you know if
you didn't wear a condom you could get a
disease oh well you're sterile way there
were condoms there were condoms in
people to rabbit skin she was about that
I just know that if you didn't wear one
and you had sex with a prostitute
chances are you'd have gotten like an
STD or you could get sterile or you
could get her knocked up and then you
have a kid and the kid could die and all
their know those weird some yeah I mean
it was so cool again just like real life
exactly so cool you can get diseases and
if you were evil you grow horns I
remember that too like yeah I do
remember here and then your dog would
actually mad a dog that was the best
part about fable to the dog is the
second time you talked about it so
unless a dog is great yeah because you
if you're a good character the dog will
get like you'll turn like into like a
golden retriever but if you're kind of
like corrupt and bad it just turns black
as I'd like he likes like a flat coat
terrier or something like that it's
weird and then I think there are even
some DLC expansion so you could actually
change the kind of dog you had like a
bloodhound or Dalmatian or husky or
something so that I I remember all that
remember three not liking it all because
we know dogs it I don't didn't have
another of at a dog I just remember not
liking it because it just it wasn't as
fun and there were so many you were you
were ruling the kingdom I could see
where they were trying to go but at the
same time I felt that there was a lack
of they'd I think they just lost their
way at some point and it was almost kind
like you were managing a kingdom and
then you know it got so we were just
like oh I just like taxes and people
yelling at me and I'm just I'm done I
know yeah they seem like like
significantly different games like and I
guess that's where like my opinion
having not really delve into these but
well what's the game I would look
forward to i don't know like it sounds
like 22 but yeah I mean up like a MOBA
fabled MOBA that's that's not like a
completely different game yeah like just
like as you said just like pulling the
name you know I know how experimentally
you get I mean before you start taking
chances it's kind of it's it's hard
right because you want to bring new
friends into the fray right but then you
want to also please the existing ones
you have I don't know if that might have
been why they had problems well you see
a game like halo wars which like people
who played it seemed to really like it
yeah but it doesn't reach the same sales
as regular halo know right
but but this is a free-to-play game so
maybe I just you know where their
transactions during the beta I doubt it
right I doubt it yeah so well either way
it is sad for fans of the series that
the game is cancelled and unfortunately
for Lionhead Studios employees that
might be losing jobs so not to make
light of the situation it sucks and if
you're looking forward to fable legends
let us know in the comments below and if
you have any great memories share those
as well alright guys before we start
talking about tim sweeney epic casting
shade on Microsoft hmm we've got the
vibe in the office we had it on the last
episode last Friday we were here late
little drunk you wouldn't matter didn't
matter you were playing this lil game
called final approach that I want to
talk about and ty I think you played it
as well I'm just glad you named it right
I i can what do I keep calling it like
control flight control like so final
approach I'm going to give us a cursory
description you play God wearing a glove
that was made in the tron universe and
you tell helicopters and planes were to
go that's all I know yeah and you and
you extinguish them when they catch on
fire I fill me in why is this so fun and
why does need via it's it's just it's
again I was probably one of the biggest
view are skeptics until we got this
thing in the office yeah and this is
obviously one of the demos we played but
when you're in there it is just it's i
think this is mary trying to screw with
the core pedestrians that live in the
city but Josh know it looks a little
Arthur but the thing is it's it's
hello I'm going to talking to the
microphone you can tell this is my first
rodeo don't move behind the sons
marriage had a heart attack over there
but it's just I really you feel like
you're Godzilla you don't feel like
you're God I feel like you feel like
you're just this giant you know thing
walking especially in the city one but
when you're in the you have like an
ocean level where you're like just in it
it's as simple as telling helicopters
and planes were to land performing tasks
someone catches on fire you have to
extinguish them look I'm gonna stop it
just sounds incredibly boring yeah what
listen I might just been crazy no I mean
like like what what is what is the like
making that the plane land are making it
crash right those are really simple
experiences like how does the overall
thing like make you feel so when I was
what I will say is having you know
trying out the oculus rift having tried
out um I think I was gonna I tried out
but regardless you put this thing on and
you're at this is the first standing VR
thing I've ever done and I'm a little
skeptical because you know with like too
deep with the dk2 we had the office yeah
yeah um I don't know that thing I could
see the pixels ray I'm just sitting in a
chair it was enjoyable this however
you're standing and you're moving around
now no let me out we I'm sitting in a
chair for the dk2 and all I'm you know I
have a controller in my hand it's it
hurts your head your head basically to
grasp okay i can look with my left or
looking with my head but my right stick
is still ingrained with like other
movement and texts this however is like
full BR and well why i will say about
this one that the resolution is
top-notch I don't notice any pixels the
precision is what really got me like
stoked and as you said like kind of like
a Tron you have this armband right I
feel like I'm Tony Stark and it's
perfect like it's like a palette and
everything is so precise that you you
could do it forever like I don't know
there's no motion sickness involved that
was a big complain with like they are
the precision was what like took me away
and you know you'll you'll have a plane
fly a director plane to like land right
and then you'll forget about and you
here late in your right speaker and you
looked you right and there at the plane
in your face flying right past
your eyes like it is why does water
physics you how amazing it's always so
hard to communicate what makes a VR
experience great because it's not it's
just not the same as looking at it on
the screen like you really have to feel
that sends a presence yeah and this is
our dilemma right i mean like how do you
explain this to somebody how do you show
it to somebody like that clip right
there with josh messing around and in
their room with the vibe on is it isn't
it's not indicative of what that
experience is really like no at all
whatsoever like the only way to tell you
about it is just a DF experience it
yourself yeah it's like love no we can
tell you you're in love Peter yeah valve
in oculus and anyone else like Sony
who's experimenting with VR has a really
tough road ahead of them because they've
got to get this stuff in people's hands
maybe it's gonna be word of mouth that
does it yeah you know oh look a real
aircraft simulator hose it down pilot I
mean that game a look boring as hell I
mean if you just watch it on this video
no on the stream but when you play it
it's it's hard to describe it just it
feels really good especially those other
demos we had 20 urate there's somebody
to talk about and you know we are
actually getting our final oculus rift
pretty soon the embargo for that list
the 28th and we're gonna start having a
whole mess of VR coverage and it's gonna
be it's gonna be interesting to see how
we do it yeah yeah um what are your
thoughts real quick on the PlayStation
VR do you think I think is actually
gonna come in under 500 bucks or not ooh
I think right now the kind of the guess
is that they are going to try to hit 500
because they want to go beneath ocular
it won't be below that but that's the
thing though is that Sony isn't just
selling the headset they have to sell a
little box that's connected to it that
does the extra processing because the
ps4 isn't doing all of it no so you had
that cost in who knows but Sony as a
console manufacturer is known for
selling Hardware at a loss to get people
in to buy the software yeah the question
is can that model work for this given
that people already need to own a
PlayStation 4 so this is a whole other
purchase so they have the installed base
which is good that's the helps but it's
asking someone to drop another 500 bones
on something that you know I only have
so many bones Sony that's it so from
Peter himself it's the library right
like that's the selling point like
what's the vibe going for now 805 is 800
and that comes with two controllers
which
riff does not the rift I think comes
with an xbox 13 stroller safety
controller and and there I can I haven't
I haven't tried the newest version of
the oculus but that vibe was probably
the best one I've tried to date in terms
of PlayStation VR or the Morpheus
whatever it was called when I tried it
and then oculus and this that was great
but you need a space for that place to
like we have like this you know strike
oh that's big but we live all we also
live in San Francisco and it's like you
know how big our apartments here we all
know it's not it's not necessarily the
best experience but you need the room
you need the room and there were a
couple of issues that were frustrating
right like you know you have this cord
like neo and matrix just like sticking
out of your head like unfortunately yeah
you're going to be you know losing track
of where you are as far as your rotation
is so like you know if you if you get
you get tangled basically just don't age
yeah and um I guess I would say like man
they beat it would be probably really
imperative to like have this thing
attached to the ceiling or maybe maybe
they'll even have like an adapter or
some like that like some kind of like
bungee system yeah um I know I can see
this thing being like you know like the
mic and like a like a fight club ladies
and gentlemen drop it like its Josh that
could work if Josh was not here like
guiding me and and help assisting me
with that thing I would have been
hitting walls knocking over his sailboat
all this other crap I mean I've been
I've been bad well the interesting thing
about the vibe and I don't know if we
had activate at that time but it has a
camera that lets you see things in your
environment it does which is great when
you can make a wall you can make like
this like gridwall where it says you can
actually outline your room and be like
all right if I get to this edge that
means there is a object right in front
of me it will also sense like like just
any object in the road doesn't have done
that bad yeah like I was in a demo ones
who they told me to sit down and I was
like the hell my gonna sit on it like
look down and I looked down and I could
see the outline of the chair so you knew
you were so I was able to sit down in VR
well I was still in the experience that
was looking there was just a little bit
of a ghostly image know which helps yeah
the dawn of VR is upon us yeah are you
guys planning on buying a VR headset do
you have the money and the VR dungeon
everyone has the money they're just
loaded everybody otay I don't know how
the hell people are gonna buy these
things I just I'm still skeptical that
they're gonna sell that well I'll think
about it and
just know in the comments below if
you're gonna pick this stuff up we're
pretty lucky we get them in but man I
could not afford this on my own now
eight hundred dollars there's library
and then you need a computer run the
damn thing yeah like we have like a 980
in that thing and and it's it's it's a
beefy machine man talking like two
thousand dollars plus yeah to run that
thing it's nuts mmhmm yeah all right
earlier this week Tim Sweeney one of the
co-founder the founders of Epic Games
came out to criticize Microsoft he wrote
like a lengthy feature talking about the
the Microsoft Windows platform it's this
new sort of an API software development
tool they're using to allow developers
to make games for all windows devices
with just one set of code yeah ports it
automatically Tim Sweeney's concern is
like okay what that's doing because
Microsoft is doing for phasing out
support for stuff Microsoft takes this
approach phases out the old sort of Wild
West win32 application system where
people could just make anything for any
version of Windows you could download
from the website and play it if they get
rid of that and it's just this uwp this
United Windows platform developers and
gamers are going to be sort of taken out
of the equation they're gonna have to go
through Microsoft for everything so ty I
know that you kind of understand a
little bit more about this yeah it's I
don't know if we I he he makes some
interesting points and I understand the
coming from his you know side why he's a
little scared right now and why he is
concerned but I don't I don't I don't
necessarily know I think there's always
going to be that side load option in
Windows 10 I'm almost positive that you
can set a security parameter that says i
can install anything you can do that
right now yes so but what happened with
Windows 8 is Microsoft eventually made
that part of only the Enterprise Edition
got it up one guys so there is a chance
maybe that's why I'm concerned yeah yeah
I mean if this is tough right I can see
both sides of the argument here I think
windows I think Microsoft smart I mean
they're they're at the stage now where I
believe like if you look at other
operating systems you know like Mac
they're growing their install base is
growing windows are shrinking you know
it's it's not as it means still the
dominant force right you know especially
with gaming you know but in I guess in
enterprise
for the most part they are losing
numbers and they need to the PC like is
a like if you ask my parents and my
grandmother it's it's a damn mess and it
drives them nuts call her up let's do
not like we should write my 91 year old
grandma hates no but no it's it's
interesting because I mean you said
yourself with the win32 API like it's
it's been very open yes but the problem
is like applications can you know they
might request access from other
applications it might be digging into
your hard drive like at no point when
you I just feel at no point when you
change your OS like should things just
break right and not work or when you
install a program it causes another
program to break and work I mean this is
why things like xbox one ps4 the ayah
phone I iPads anything any closed
ecosystem is popular because it's made
for ninety percent of the people ninety
percent of the time right but if you
look at the sort of control Microsoft is
trying to have over everything up that
puts like it's alarming well I mean cuz
developers now can put out any app they
want right on game shows you can
download it install it through this this
uwp Microsoft has to approve they do
everything right and we've seen how that
works on the Apple App Store where
certain things get denied for sometimes
just like cold systemic reasons like
it's sort of putting at least this is my
opinion like it's putting these sort of
like lock and key on things that have
forever it's been open and you know
people have to be smart enough to
navigate open waters mm-hmm but i'm not
sure that can i mean think about it this
way this is a whole other platform that
people have to consider on pc like we've
already got seen which everyone loves
yes and you've got you play and you've
got origin is origin still a thing right
origin is still think they try to like
rebrand it the thing is we i don't know
we don't need a whole other one well
then that's the appeal of a pc right
exactly is well using source yeah that's
why i have it okay i mean i'm talking
like to the average person though like I
think to us you i agree with you guys
one hundred percent i think we want to
get like some there was a think in
Sweeney's article there was like
something talked about how like there's
like this element of like danger and
excitement that you feel when you have a
pc and like it just don't open that
something just works right and you're
just like that we're
I can't believe I got that to work you
know I mean and part of the reason why a
lot of the developers are worried is
because like you look at like rise of
the Tomb Raider on Windows 10 that was a
mess like that that game didn't even let
you run full screen like it was a
windowed full screen didn't take full
advantage of the video card there were
some other weird like SLI problems with
that game but you know you download on
steam it works perfectly right so I get
all that but the same time is like you
know how big is like the audience like
us that uses pcs the game and do all
this other weird [ __ ] like how big are
we compared to the general enterprise
type audience creative audience that
just wants a goddamn computer to work
properly right but you I think it was
you that was telling me that your
computer wanted to update to Windows 10
that pissed me off and you had left auto
update on to be fair yes the problem is
if my really piss me off if Microsoft
does this right like a gay no gears of
war ultimate edition yeah only available
on Windows 10 with directx 12 which
presented a bunch of problems for people
yeah again I'm I'm not defend I'm not
like defending are supporting the
decision I'm just I can understand why
they're doing it now that's what I'm
coming from like I agree yeah made me
really mad when I like when windows tim
was about to install automatically and i
was like what the hell and then it by
the way it also downloaded the damn
thing to my computer and a hidden drive
that i couldn't delete and then when i
did delete it it reinstalled it again or
downloaded again so yeah there's some
shady [ __ ] going on there and it made me
mad but the thing is is like how off
like they're pushing so aggressively
with this right they want everyone to
adopt Windows 10 and they're going to
force you to do it you know like there I
feel like they're they're kind of taking
some cues from Apple but they're just
getting a lot more [ __ ] for it and it's
it's it's interesting is there concern
that they'll be taking a cut from they
are taking it they are what's that yeah
it's the same thirty seventy percent
amazing thing yeah i mean i think so i
don't know you know for sure i'm almost
positive is thirty percent you some I i
say this with absolutely no conviction
whatsoever but i think it's i think
their store they are taking a cut yeah
yeah it would make sense that they would
but they are allowing you to download
uwp certified applications from other
sources right like phil spencer said
that like they are allowing you to do
that so it's i understand why everyone's
kind of freaking out I just don't I just
think the jury's still out I don't think
people should just freaked out for no
reason without listening to all the
facts and hearing what's going on
because I would love to make the pc
gaming experience better right like just
smoother and I mean I we do all of our
work in pc like with you know with Adobe
Creative Cloud and like all these other
applications that we use you know like I
I need them to work and when they don't
work and [ __ ] just breaks it is very
frustrating well it's especially with
Adobe I mean like that almost presents
its own issue because in the past you
could just have those apps not have to
worry about connecting to the cloud to
like yo make sure your license was good
oh yeah now it's all the time I mean
it's a sign of things changing for the
worse yeah it's like a nightmare now
when like something updates an Adobe
Creative Cloud and then like half your
[ __ ] doesn't work so I mean it would be
great to have some sort of uniformity
there but the same time I understand why
you know some gamers are you know antsy
get it is this a concern I mean I know
gear so gears is obviously a microsoft
exclusive so is that just the main
concern is that like all exclusive say
halo down the road wants to make its way
to PC it it will have to go through the
system is basically what the idea is
also the idea is that if Microsoft takes
away the ability to sideload apps into
uwp or the ability to release
downloadable exe files based on the old
win32 method then everyone will have to
go through UW piano is constrained one
they might not have to sell it through
that store they won't have to do that at
least not okay don't have to do right no
but that's the concern right that's
where it's all coming from and so if
they have to do that sure they could
still sell the game through steam but
they would have to conform to the tools
and the policies that are that I hearin
in being part of UW and that may not be
such a horrible thing if you sell
through a third party store but then at
least you have that uwp certification it
says hey this app is just going to
install it's not going to go fishing
through your [ __ ] it's not going to look
for anything else it's not going to
install anything nefarious it's gonna
screw up something else it's legit
because we you know absurd it we served
it yeah and that part actually I like i
might be getting crucified by a bunch of
pc game i'm sure you are yeah but I mean
I like that part of it but at the same
time I understand like you know it's
also a giant corporation they want to
make money and and I get all that so I
get the concerns I just think that the
jury's still out alright well are you
guys worried about the future of Windows
gaming why do you love gaming on PC in
the first place I know for me was always
downloading those
incredibly not ignore I'm going with
this never mind pc gaming the Wild West
might be able to i know i was gonna get
inappropriate all right gentlemen this
has been the episode of the lobby I
thank you for letting me host it and
thank you for joining me thank you for
having me it's my first time in this
room oh my goodness no it's not ever I
was summoned you to find job posting i
just stumbled upon you and then yeah
it'll the show um I want to thank Eric
teh Mary Kish and Josh Shaw and the back
also Richard Lee in the front Josh Shaw
it is his last day at gamespot I want
Josh ought to come in here right now I
want him to come in and do a little
dance I don't think you will Joshua come
in I'm not gonna stop talking until you
come in yeah and I'm gonna tell people
Josh's course he's not here he's
Chessie's checkity check he's gone they
already kicked him out he's gone it's
gone Oh what I will miss him but before
all round Evernote um Eric Tay and I
will be streaming some more division
okay high-level playa right after this
so 3 30 ish you can see some high-level
stuff air k is a level Eric day and I
played Jesus I play till 3am and almost
passed out and I had seen my fondest the
air cave it I'll be knows most people I
think that man can grind he got two
hours of sleep last night I woke up at
four-thirty to go run and he was still
playing that [ __ ] game yeah I don't
understand it like my last visual is
like I have to go to bed cuz I'm falling
asleep and I'm likes watching air run
down the street of New York City Erik
played till 5am he's level 26 I'm 20 so
what you will be seeing is basically
some sort of high-level play of me being
carried by Eric day so it could be a
very interesting stream day and Luke
games men I know he likes that stuff he
loves it does he does alright so make
sure to join us next week everyone we
will be back at Tuesday at two p.m. for
another episode of the lobby and please
if you're listening on iTunes leave us
some comments let us know what you like
what you don't let us know if you think
I should be hosting the show instead of
Danny probably not but I'd appreciate
the feedback okay marriage life hey fair
enough hey all right hi all right all
right guys take it easy